let's talk not just about removing
Donald Trump but removing a malignant
Republicans from the Senate as well one
of the things I would love to see in
November of 2020 is a prominent
Republican senator defeated we know that
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has multiple challengers it's an uphill
battle it's going to be a tough one but
it's one worth fighting there's another
interesting one which is South Carolina
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham whose
challenger Jamie Harrison raised more
than three and a half million dollars
during the fourth quarter of 2019 this
is more than listen to this he raised
more than any South Carolina Democrat
has ever raised in a quarter in the
history of South Carolina
he now has more than four point six
million dollars on hand
normal caveats here a very often in red
states the Democratic challengers are
pretty centrist establishment types
jamie Harrison is a centrist
establishment type he's a DNC official
former chairman of the South Carolina
DNC campaign is backed by the DSCC
but this is still good news because
Lindsey Graham has been one of the most
vocal Trump brown nosers during the last
thirty years culminating maybe with this
absolutely unhinged rant did I say 30
years I meant three years unhinged rant
in support of Donald Trump's often
accused of sexual assault Supreme Court
picked Brett Kavanaugh remember when a
Lindsey Graham appeared to have a
medical incident from how crazy he went
during those hearings take a look at
this if you wanted an FBI investigation
you could have come to us what you want
to do is destroy this guy's life hold
this seat open and hope you win in 2020
you've said that not me you've got
nothing to apologize for when you see
soda Meyer and cake and tell them that
Lindsey said all because I voted for
them I would never do to them what
you've done to this guy this is the most
unethical sham since I've been in
politics and if you really
wanted to know the truth you sure as
hell wouldn't have done what you've done
to this guy are you a gang rapist
No yeah so it would be a great
accomplishment to knock out Lindsey
Graham it is a huge uphill battle back
in 2014 in very red South Carolina
Lindsay won by 17 points 55 to 38 over a
grotto guy named Brad Hutto but Jamie
Harrison is raising more money Lindsey
Graham might have some liability hanging
on him because of his association with
Trump we just don't know yet Jamie
Harrison is a really long shot for sure
but anything can happen in any race and
a year the polls aren't looking great at
the the the polling we actually have no
really good polling in South Carolina we
have a six-month-old poll a from change
research where Lindsey was polling 70%
but Jamie Harrison wasn't even in that
poll and now Jamie Harrison has nearly 5
million dollars to spend so I don't
think we can read too much into the
polling one way or the other other to
say other than to say it will be a tough
one it's fun to dream but imagine if
both Lindsey Graham and Mitch McConnell
were to lose their seats in the same
election cycle unlikely but let's work
every race like it's potentially
winnable the fact alone that candidates
for historically non competitive Senate
seats like South Carolina and Kentucky
are even able to raise this much money
tells us a lot it's also sort of
frustrating that some candidates in more
competitive states like North Carolina
and Georgia are having trouble raising
money that actually is not good but
let's remember the lessons from the
midterms of 2018 you know when when
Democrats took over the house in 2018 I
remember that there was satisfaction to
some degree but also kind of a feeling
of helplessness like what can what can
we really do with taking over the house
Trump his executive orders his cabinet
the Senate well because Democrats took
over the house in 2018 Donald Trump has
been impeached becoming only the third
president in history to be impeached now
that may go nowhere it may it certainly
is not likely to lead to Donald Trump's
conviction in the Senate it may help to
remove Donald Trump
voting him out in November of 2020 but
this is why every single one of these
races has to be fought every single one
of these Senate races that could be
taken from a Republican has to be fought
were only a few seats from a majority in
the Senate I've looked at the numbers
I've told you it's tough 20:22 is more
likely but we all given that we're
likely to lose one seat in the Senate we
only need to pick up five in order to
take over control it is not impossible
and we should be fighting for it
the 2018 midterms and Trump now being
impeached are Exhibit A as to why this
matters